ces terribles images ont été tournées
environ 15 minutes avant le sauvetage de
jacqueline du monde martèle la femme de
85 ans est alors seul sur son balcon en
chaque été pendant toute la nuit et
glacial et là tant de manières que oui
elle sera dans son combat par des
policiers son sauveteur n'a que 28 ans
deux ans et demi d'expérience comme
pompier mais d'abord comme
préventionniste well as plein même c'est
comme ça qu'on l'a vue parce que
beaucoup de fumée abouti il y avait des
flammes à travers donc c'est comme ceux
qu'on rencontre les repérer et à au
deuxième étage oui on est un peu la mode
à la table on lui disait de sauter mais
elle va pas tu es capable
donc c'est un voile 6,15 à une échelle
puis on l'installé de son balcon
il est sur place pour inquiéter mais
devant la situation qui dégénère
son supérieur l'affect au sauvetage au
total il en réalisera trois avec l'aide
de policiers
c'est un très mince et toutes les
situations qu'on a déjà vécu qui ont ce
report cela ne paye que le lien a bar
puis
elle est aussi comme celle qui fait
qu'on est capable de faire ça parce
qu'on les forme et plus con qu'on gère
bien notre stress quand il a dragué
l'idée d'action comme ça aussi
onze mois après le drame madame dumont
martel se dit elle-même miraculés se
porte bien et préfère un souper de
remerciement pour le jeune pompier ici
de nier le dieu que radio-canada à
rimouski